I don't really think I've ever really
talked to my live driver about problems
I remember once my lip drivers psychic
me that was special whenever I use an
uber or lyft for work I'd walk in say hi
let go of my phone right away I think
sometimes I talked to my lyft driver
when I'm drunk
we have great conversations maintaining
a kind of healthy lifestyle well really
busy at work is what I'm going through
right now I think I just need like a
hobby that I'm not trying to make into
like work I'm really curious some more
delve deeper and to see if maybe there's
something that I'm not knowing about
myself I think it's just weird talking
just somewhat about my feelings I talk
to myself sometimes but see how this
goes my name is sherry Smith and I've
been driving for left three and a half
years I've had people talk about
relationship issues about what he's done
and they just starts talking about it
I'm not gonna like give my opinion I
just keep asking questions once it hits
the airwaves it becomes real I'm from
New Jersey originally okay it moved out
here for school so what'd you study it
was business with the marketing focus
okay and then I did a job in that for
like what like three months and then I
was I realized quickly that I hated it
and I needed to do something creative so
I started working towards that I try to
encourage them to follow their passion
are you doing this because somebody said
you had to do this or you doing it
because it's what you really want to do
right now it's kind of like my job is
kind of everything just because it's
important to me to do well and I am in
like it's pretty competitive take time
for a personal life I tried to you're
young I feel like you're there kind of
bleeding away
no they're not yeah but you still need
to take Tyler to have the last few drops
I had I'd approach every single job
opportunity afraid that I wasn't good
enough or nothing like screw up the job
and coming here and being able to do
videos and make things it's just like
[ __ ] I'm doing something right you
know there's just something about
venting your life to a stranger when you
know that there are gonna be no
repercussions of it it's just nice and
light oh dude so I get in these
conversations with my passengers I like
to feel about to see where they're going
in life what their goals are long term
goal I really want a phone restaurant
I'm also like I'm gay so and I really
love like film and TV shows as well so
if I could ever like produce TV shows or
movies that have like a food and clear
focus that'd be like awesome and I'd be
like the dream life well sound like you
has a good play been told it's like I
have plans a through these you know
hopefully some laugh tell him your plans
like the fact that they can talk to
strangers and they don't they can be
themselves it definitely felt a little
bit more relaxed after my vendor session
with Sheri it was like in the middle of
the workday so just to be able to take
that break and then come back to work
was a nice refresher
throughout the day especially when
you're working so much you're kind of
like in your own world and she was
really open to talking about anything
and it really depends on what kind of
energy you're putting out there if I'm
like energetic about it didn't guess
they will open up and I like that and I
think they like it too that's why I'm a
5 star driver
[Laughter]